[MUSIC PLAYING]
With big data, we've come to
expect big responsibility.
In order to handle the
complexity of today's data,
you need to spend
a lot on hardware,
plan ahead for
scalability, and pour hours
into system architecture.
It's no joke.
And this just gets
you up and running.
You still need someone-- no, a
team to make sure everything's
running smoothly.
And even after
all that headache,
running queries can still take
anywhere from minutes to hours,
and mistakes can be costly.
Wouldn't you rather focus on
finding insights from your data
than developing the
infrastructure around it?
Google BigQuery is a fully
managed data warehouse
that removes set up hassles and
runs queries rocket fast, fast
enough to analyze
terabytes of the data
in seconds,
petabytes in minutes.
Google BigQuery works on
a pay-as-you-go basis.
You only pay for
the bytes processed.
What if you have a
really big query?
It's simple.
We'll spin up an
entire data center
to quickly process it for you.
Just sit back, and let
us handle the scaling.
Google BigQuery
encrypts, replicates,
and deploys your data
across multiple data
centers for maximum durability
and service up time.
With just a couple
of clicks, you
can control where
you store your data.
Sharing and collaboration
are easy as well.
You decide who can
access your data.
And because you can use
standard SQL queries,
anyone can get involved.
Plus, BigQuery integrates
with Google Cloud Platform
products and other
software, so you can readily
load, process, and make
interactive visualizations
of your data.
It's never been easier to
analyze massive data sets
and find insights fast
with Google BigQuery.
Head to
cloud.google.com/bigquery.